monsieur roy monsieur le premier
ministre félicitations merci beaucoup
avait bien choses vont vite
oui beaucoup de travail m'excite
vraiment une victoire décisive net
est-ce que quelques jours avant
vous espérez encore sur vous disiez ça
sera plus possible donc n'espérez
gouvernement majoritaire à 74 ça vous a
surpris l'emploi il ya quelques endroits
là entre autres en outaouais on pensait
peut-être faire une percée eu trois
députés quelques endroits bat pierre
moreau donc non il ya eu quand même
quelques surprises
mais on espérait un gouvernement
majoritaire à grande victoire arrive de
grandes responsabilités aussi les
attentes sont très élevées
comment vous allez montre aux québécois
que du que le québec change comme vous
avez dit dans les premières années
par exemple pendant des finances quand
est ce que les québécois vont sentir
qu'un changement
ben fictivement c'était un thème
important de dire on va remettre de
l'argent en portefeuille des québécois
déjà j'ai parlé avec celui que j'ai
nommé secrétaire général pour regarder
différentes options au ministère des
finances
c'est pas nécessaire de déposer un
budget pour mettre en place de
l'exposition agir avant noël faut voir
mais c'est possible de mettre en place
des mesures fiscales sans déposer un
mini budget donc je tenterai déjà de
faire travailler les gens évidemment il
y aura ensuite le jeu quitte pour leur
mini pour le sommet de la francophonie
la formation du conseil des ministres et
après on pourrait travailler en
éducation en santé mais oui je veux
qu'ils aient des résultats mais je peux
je veux faire ça dans l'ordre on a
quatre ans on va voir des changements
mais je veux faire ça dans l'ordre avec
l'adhésion des employés mais comme par
exemple et les frais de garderie ramener
ça à 8 dollars 5 pour tout le monde
parce que c'est dans la première année
que les genres on sort on va regarder
les différentes mesures fiscales les
mesures fiscales
on a pris les engagements sur les quatre
ans mais il y en a peut-être certaines
qu'on peut mettre en place tout de suite
et moi je veux qu'il y en a certaines
qui soient mises en place tout de suite
que les québécois sans que oui qui ont
de l'argent de plus dans leurs poches
ok mais pas nécessairement un mini
budget avant noël votre vie implanté
certaine mesure sans passer par tout ça
il ya eu depuis deux jours c'est un peu
surréaliste comme des bols débat des
signes religieux qui a repris au québec
est-ce que là dessus vous êtes prêt à
mettre peut-être de côté la question des
enseignants peut-être demander un renvoi
la cour suprême puis aller de l'avant
tout de suite avec ce qui fait consensus
est à dire les gens d'autorité et damman
d'abord ce qui est important dit c'est
que moi j'ai trois grandes priorités
l'économie l'éducation la santé
donc c'est pas dans ces trois grandes
priorités par contre dossier des signes
religieux
je crois qu'on intérêt les québécois un
médecin derrière nous rapidement donc ce
soit adoptée dans une première année
mais engagement est clair que mon
programme est clair j'ai pas changé
d'idée
donc on veut mettre en place ce qui pour
moi est un consensus
le rapport bouchard taylor en ajoutant
les enseignants fait quand même
consensus au québec donc de dire les
personnes qui sont en autorités ne
pourront pas porter de signes religieux
les québécois qui nous écoutent la
majorité sont d'accord avec çà je pense
qu'on a intérêt à mettre ça en place
rapidement les québécois vous avez
raison tous les sondages le monde sont
d'accord avec ça mais les québécois ne
sont pas d'accord à mettre des gens de
les renvoyer que des enseignantes
on leur dit vous savez vous si vous
enlevez pas le voile c'est au revoir ça
les gens de la misère mais est ce que là
dessus vous pourriez pas à mettre de
l'eau dans votre vin ou demandeur renvoi
la cour suprême déjà maintenant non par
contre ce qu'on peut faire mieux dès
jeudi
ces deux offres et des postes dans les
bureaux ce qui est important c'est une
personne qui est en autorité puis nous
on pense qu'un enseignant une
enseignante qui est avec un jeune jeunes
est en position d'autorité mais si la
personne va aller travailler dans les
bulles
on peut y travailler dans les bureaux
mais pour nous c'est clair les personnes
en autorité ne devront pas porter de
signes religieux et si une contestation
qui en aura vu écrit dans le ciel du lot
lendemain tout ça peut être gelé pendant
quelques années
bon on pense les gens qu'on a consultées
pensent que c'est possible de le faire
juridiquement mais si c'est nécessaire
on utilisera la clause nonobstant
maternelle 4 à monsieur legault et j'ai
cru comprendre dans votre premier point
de presse que voulez vous disiez
l'important dans le fond c'est le
dépistage des enfants qui ont des
difficultés mais le cadre on peut en
discuter est ce que vous vous mettez de
l'eau dans votre vin sur une maintenant
quatre ans vous dites ça sera pour tous
les québécois l'engagement qu'on a pris
c'est de 10 dans cinq ans tous les
enfants qui veulent aller à la
maternelle pourront avoir une place dans
cinq dossiers
ça ça change ça change pas à court terme
à court terme la majorité des enfants de
4 ans ont peu de place ni en garderie ni
en maternelle 4 1 et on a besoin aussi
d'un dépistage donc d'identifier les
enfants qui est un trouble d'attention
dysphasie dyslexie otis rapidement
commencé à donner des services
rapidement parce qu'actuellement nous
sommes choc quand j'entends des parents
me dis soit j'ai besoin d'attendre un an
à saint justin où je t'oublie de payer
pour aller faire évaluer mon enfant au
privé ce sens me forge
je trouve que dans une société moderne
ça devrait pas exister donc le dépistage
ça commence le identifie les enfants qui
ont des difficultés
est ce que dans les premières années
pour faire une partie du travail dans
des cpe dans des garderies tout dans des
maternelles 80 parce qu'on a quand même
cinq ans avant d'être capable d'offrir
la maternelle quatre ans tout le monde
oui je suis ouvert et puis moi je ne
sais pas que travailler avec les gens
des cpe des gens des garderies mais vous
avez entendu les gens du milieu entre
autres à montréal mais ailleurs au
québec des gens dire que tu manques de
placement de personnel il manque
d'enseignants je veux bien maternelle
quatre ans pour tout le monde mais ce
n'est pas réel et donc vous avez entendu
ça aussi
j'entends souvent même temps bon ça fait
partie aussi des objectifs qu'on devrait
se donner de valoriser la profession
d'enseignant
donc nous on veut augmenter le salaire
des enseignants pour les six premières
années donc les six premiers échelons
on pense aussi qu'en commençant à
travailler à l'âge de quatre ans avec
les enfants qui ont des difficultés
d'apprentissage
quand ces enfants là bas on arrivait à 5
ans la maternelle il y aura moins de
difficultés pour les enseignants puis on
veut aussi augmenter le nombre d'autos
faune et surtout pédagogue pour parce
que souvent les enseignants ce qu'ils
nous disent c'est bon si j'ai dans ma
classe deux enfants qui ont des
difficultés d'apprentissage savoir si
j'en ai dix ça ne voit plus vous
continuez vous maintenez le cap parce
que lors du débat de radio canada vous
m'aviez dit vous aviez duo québécois
ça c'est la promesse je serais même prêt
à démissionner là dessus donc ça reste
essentiel pour vous ça vienne toucher
profondément parce que vous savez
aujourd'hui la mer il ya 26 % des
enfants qui ont des difficultés
d'apprentissage j'ai beaucoup la
majorité de ces enfants n'obtiennent pas
de diplôme pourtant la majorité de ces
enfants leur ont le potentiel d'obtenir
un diplôme donc d'abord pour le bien de
ses enfants alors même pour notre
société
on a le devoir de leur donner des
services puis agir taule c'est la
solution recommandée par tous les
spécialistes santé qu'est ce que les
québécois vont voir changer dans le
domaine de la santé dans la première
moitié du mandat m bon c'est pas sain le
réseau de la santé
le geste le plus important que ça se
voie pas le jour au lendemain c'est de
renégocier une nouvelle entente avec les
médecins de famille et on a beaucoup
parlé des spécialistes jour on doit
parler d'argent mais les médecins de
famille actuellement 60% des patients
qui sont à l'urgence ne devrait pas être
à l'urgence
ce sont des comme mineurs qui auraient
dû être traités en cabinet privé ou en
clsc par un médecin de famille ou une
infirmière redistribuer autrement mais
ça suppose de revoir le mode
combien de temps sera votée ce fait
c'est ça qu'il faut voir si on est
capable de faire ça hein on s'accroche
rush tous une médaille d'or c'est pas
simple de négocier que les deux
fédérations de médecins mais en même
temps je pense qu'on est arrivé là je
pense qu'il ya beaucoup de médecins de
famille qui se disent ben voyons donc il
va falloir donner plus de services qu'on
appelle de première ligne aux patients
et en même temps vous voulez toujours
aller chercher votre milliards du côté
des médecins spécialistes
quand vous aurez le rapport d'un
comparaisons salariales et l'ontario
mais là j'ai parlé avec notre nouveau
secrétaire général j'ai demandé si on
pouvait devancer parce que le rapport de
comparaison avec l'ontario que le reste
du canada est prévue pour l'automne 2010
9 faut dire que techniquement on
pourrait pas commencer à négocier avant
l'automne 2010 9 semble que c'est long
est-ce qu'on devrait pas être capable
d'avoir une étude comparative
avant ça mais c'est aussi une demande
que j'ai je vous avais mis la barre
haute aussi pour les en disant aux
québécois je vais vous on attendra pas
davantage que 90 minutes dans les
urgences on voit ça à la fin du mandat
on arrivait à huy à la fin du mandat
mais ce existe déjà par exemple à
l'hôpital juif depuis sa télé les gens
vont savoir jouer mais ils réussissent
quand même les derniers chiffres du
buste à 91 mais ne way et sont très
achalandé à l'hôpital juif donc il ya
une question d'organisation
mais je reviens avec mes médecins de
famille c'est certain qu'ils si on
arrive à sortir une partie importante
des patients dans nos salles d'urgences
d'hôpitaux mais ça va prendre moins d'un
sur le goal entente qu'on a signés
canada etats unis mexique est ce qu'elle
est bonne nous lé pas bonnes pour le
québec
bon les peaux bonne pour nos producteurs
agricoles en particulier nos producteurs
laitiers mais si on compare avec ne pas
avoir d'entente avec les états unis est
en année qu'on a une balance commerciale
très positive
le québec et les états unis c'est une
bonne chose par contre il reste je vais
rencontrer les gens du pays et y reste
des points à régler d'un on n'a pas le
texte final en français pour l'instant
ce qui est prévu c'est de limiter les
exportations de certains produits
partout dans le monde dans une entente
avec les états unis nous les médecins
nous disent à qui on va vendre ses
soeurs puis les avocats qui disent c'est
peut-être même pas légal avec une
poignée au québec si vous n'êtes pas
content c'est ça c'est de dire est ce
que légalement le canada les etats unis
le mexique peuvent limiter les
exportations du québec de certains
produits comme le lait cru mais est ce
qu'ils peuvent aussi nous empêcher
d'avoir des classes là c'est compliqué
la classe 7 mai ils ce sont des points
légaux si vous avez pas contents mais
ton à la fin de l'analyse qu'est ce
qu'est ce qui reste au québec comme
pouvoir il ya des possibilités de
contestation judiciaire aura fait
ensuite c'est évidemment des
compensations rafale v2g monsieur la
première a démissionné le jour du vote
station usité est ce que vous vous
l'auriez mis à la porte
écoutez moi j'aurais voulu avec
l'opposition pour vous respecter cet
engagement que la personne qui soit
nommé ou reconduites soit appuyée par le
deux tiers de l'assemblée nationale mais
il arrive au mien l'apport mais écoutez
moi j'aurais voulu en discuter avec
l'opposition moi je veux avoir une
personne qui au delà de tout soupçon qui
est appuyée par le deux tiers des
députés de l'assemblée nationale mais la
question se pose bus et partent en
vacances et les ministres paritaire ça
c'est pour vous sur évidence
moitié-moitié à quel moment à quel
moment vous allez présenter aux
québécois votre guide pour une semaine
en arménie la semaine suivante là on
voit pas mal est rendu là donc
présentation de votre wii prenez
exercice pas facile non des jauges est
là dedans quitte à la santé madame
écartée je vous ferai pas de donnerai
pas de cours aujourd'hui
mais ce que je peux vous dire c'est
qu'il ya 74 personnes de qualité
là je dois en choisir une vingtaine
c'est très 10 puis j'en parlais que
philippe couillard lui aussi le tous les
premiers ministres des huit rallyes
c'est peut-être là la partie la plus
difficile
françois legault merci félicitations
encore merci monsieur reparler ont versé
au revoir